you might have missed this because
everyone's so focused overseas but this
week during a white house press call
we learned the biden administration is
thinking about reviving the old see
something say something campaign
implemented after the attacks on 911
coming up on 20 years now
but this time it won't be used to report
radical islamic terrorists instead
americans will be encouraged to report
radical members of their own family
who might just be white supremacists you
never know the administration also plans
to work closely with tech companies on
quote
increased information sharing to combat
further radicalization
dan bongino is all over this he's the
host of unfiltered on dan bongino on
saturday night's
unbelievable start first two weeks he's
also the host of the dan bongino show
comes on right after you're done
listening to me uh at noon until three
o'clock eastern time
available on fox nation so you can see
exactly what he looks like like he does
now
first off dan were you surprised that a
9 11
type style investigation will be
happening domestically
yeah i i mean i am and and he sees
something say something campaigns i mean
does that apply to blm and antifa too
i mean brian are you telling me you know
the mommies and these antifa kids who
none of them have actual jobs i mean
they're total life losers
if you had a list of criteria this
dude's a life loser
all boxes are checked are you telling me
the moms of these losers didn't see the
ninja suits in the corner
the black goggles the kerosene to burn
the stores down
does this apply to them too because if
not it seems to me
and listen let me just get this out
right away because i mean it i condemn
all political violence in this country
we do
our deeds electorally in the election
booth period
i condemn it all everybody clear but if
you're going to say on one hand listen
if you were at a mag a rally uh on on
january 6 say you were
someone who didn't do anything you just
went to the rally and you didn't like
what happened in the election it was
your right to assemble
and someone should report you but again
you've got a ninja suit in your closet
a couple of sticks to beat people with
and you're ready to go to an antifungal
don't say anything there
then brian that's not justice justice is
supposed to be blind to everyone
you know not just blind to democrats
with an eye wide open
towards anyone who's a republican so dan
i have i have a hunch you know the
attorney general's coming out and said
we're going to look at domestic
organization terror organizations
go ahead uh if there's a domestic terror
organization
looking to do another oklahoma attack
you've got to be kidding me
get rid of them get rid of them i have a
sense that if they do a true
investigation
they're not going to find the numbers
that they think they're going to find
not even close
so this could help solve the problem and
stop painting america
as white and black or white and
everybody else
yep what's the hallmark right what's the
fingerprint of totalitarian regimes this
is what worries me
where we're going now it's what i called
on my show today brian reverse
intelligence
how does intelligence work professional
nonpartisan unbiased intelligence
operators
provide decision makers with facts and
data hey there's a nuclear site in
russia whatever they
may be and the decision makers make a
decision that's not where we are now
we're in an environment of reverse
intelligence lawmakers like biden and
the liberals
tell the intelligence agencies hey
here's what we're looking for we're
looking for a narrative that white
supremacy
is not a problem which we agree it is
the number one problem
we want to make it the number one
problem and that's where we're going to
allocate our assets and then what
happens
politicized intelligence people go out
and tell them what he wants to hear
we saw it with that ridiculous dhs
report claiming somehow white supremacy
is the number one
threat in the united states that i mean
that's insane who actually believes that
that's insane above
china above china chinese domestic
espionage here
within the united states russia isis al
qaeda come on
seriously so as the president heads home
and the
the focus justily comes back home
we're going to take a look at the vice
president's trip over to mexico and
guatemala
and it was an abject disaster she's
gotten a pass because everyone quickly
focused on the g7 the nato summit and
now uh the vladimir putin summit
when we come back there's already going
to be pressure on her from another
democrat henry cuellar
he did it again in a letter he said come
to the border this is a problem we're
all affected you need to see this
what's going to change is the problem
bad enough where other media outlets
will actually agree that attention has
to be done and so far she's failed in
epic ways
no no they won't because they'll never
do that until there's not a price to be
paid by a democrat right
so there's a midterm election coming up
so the media we all know i mean it's not
a secret they're full-time democrat
operatives you know so breaking news
there
but they won't do any of that because
there'll be a political price to pay
they should be asking brian cnn if they
were a legitimate news network would
have a counter in the corner like they
did for the coronavirus
under trump days since kamala harris
hasn't been to the border they would do
that if they were legitimate if it was
trump and it was a crisis they would
but they're not going to do that because
there's a price to pay after the
midterms
who knows maybe we'll hear about it but
i doubt it these aren't legitimate news
organizations
they're just useful idiots for
propaganda teams on the left
dan bongino he's got an empire he's got
a podcast
he's got a radio show that streams on
fox nation and just for fun he does a
show on saturday night and then he goes
out and parties
all day sunday and back to work on
monday who signed you up for this
schedule
it's incredible dan thanks so much
appreciate it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else